new york die uno die derzeit
stattfindende generalversammlung begann
mit einem klimagipfel zu diesem gipfel
machte sich auch die bedauernswerte
greta mit der super segel jahr eines
milliardärs auf und verursachte damit
mindestens sechsmal so viel vom teufel
zeug co2 als wenn sie sich wie die
meisten ins flugzeug gesetzt hätte am
rande des klimagipfels später in was
erlauben strunz man hier zu denen an
ihren lippen kleben den politikern
engine lobby vertretern die einen
nannten es eine emotionale rede die sie
aufgeweckt habe andere die typische
ausdrucksweise eines an asperger syndrom
leidenden bedauernswerten kindes
diejenigen die dieses kind wiederholt
ins rampenlicht zerren
ihre kindheit zerstören sie als
legitimation für ihre kranke politik
benutzen machen sich zwar nicht
juristisch doch aber moralisch des
kindesmissbrauchs schuldig die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar dass es wohl
der wichtigste satz in unserem
grundgesetz
sie treten die würde dieses kindes mit
seiner zur schau stellung mit füßen und
wofür um ihre desaströse politik und die
interessen des öko industriellen
komplexes durchzusetzen schämen sie sich
es gab es gab aber auch gute meldungen
im vorfeld des klimagipfels ein gericht
über führte michael man den erfinder der
hockey stick kurve dem gral der klima
ist erika praktisch des betruges die
kurve sollte beweisen dass die
temperaturen in den letzten
jahrhunderten leicht sanken und seit der
industrialisierung steil ansteigen
die hockey stick kurve wurde seitdem als
beleg für eine unnatürliche erwärmung
genutzt und allein im dritten bericht
des sogenannten weltklimarates fast 70
mal erwähnt das gericht hatte sowie
viele andere wissenschaftler vorher men
aufgefordert seine rohdaten und
algorithmen mit denen er seine kurve
berechnet haben wollte offenzulegen mann
weigerte sie sich und somit ist die
hockey stick kurve tod pause
die klima ist erika die wir verbrennen
schreien haben ihr hauptargument
verloren sie stehen quasi nackt da
hertha ließ generalsekretär der
weltorganisation für meteorologie einer
der größten klima am ehesten in der
vergangenheit warnte vor einer klima
hysterie und skurrilen forderungen wie
beispielsweise wegen des klimawandels
keine kinder mehr zu bekommen
solche forderungen gibt es ausgelöst von
einer hysterie die keine
wissenschaftliche grundlage hat und
schließlich haben mehr als 500
wissenschaftler in einem brief an
un-generalsekretär gut er ist mit dem
titel es gibt keinen klima notstand der
these vom menschengemachten klimawandel
widersprochen unterschrieben unter
anderem vom früheren hannover hamburger
umweltsenator fritz vahrenholt von der
spd
in dem brief heißt es die klimamodelle
auf denen die internationalen
politikansätze derzeit aufbauend sind
ungeeignet es sei grausam und unklug
sich auf basis der resultate von solche
kindischen modellen dafür einzusetzen
billionen zu verschwenden
am montag war ich bei einer am montag
war ich bei einer podiumsdiskussion mit
allen anderen im bundestag vertretenden
parteien
zum abschluss stellt die moderatorin die
frage ob hier als afd beim klima paket
nicht mit allen anderen parteien an
einem strang ziehen könnten
ich antwortete hier diese energiewende
zerstört unsere autoindustrie unser
kraftwerks und schwerindustrie ist die
zerstört unsere kern und kohlekraftwerke
mit den anderen parteien an einem strang
zu ziehen würde bedeuten wir
beteiligungen uns an der zerstörung der
wirtschaftlichen existenz unseres landes
und das werden wir niemals tun wir
werden uns wehren uns dieser zerstörung
mit aller kraft entgegenstemmen darauf
mein wort ein freundliches glück auf
meine heimat vor allen dingen nachdem
walter vielen dank
[Applaus]